كرواتيا ولا الارجنتين ميسي ولا مودريتش
مين الاقرب للتاهل ومين اللي قدم مستويات
افضل على مدار البطوله حتى الان بكل صدق
منتخب الجميع يعني قبل مباراه كرواتيا
والبرازيل اذا سالت اي واحد ماشي في
الشارع مرحبا لو سمحت اعطيني توقعك لو
مباراه كرواتيا والبرازيل اذا حكى لك او
قال لك كرواتي او كان جواب كرواتيا بيكون
مشعوذ لانه ما في اي سبب يخليك يرشح
كرواتيا على حساب البرازيل قياسا
للمستويات اللي قدمتها كرواتيا على مدار
البطوله اليوم امام الارجنتين
منطقيا اسهل من البرازيل ك- مستوى قدمته
على مدار مباريات المسابقه كلها من اول
يوم وحتى الان ولكن ارجنتين عند لاعب يعني
عن اربع او خمس ثعابين بالبرازيل وهو
بالتاكيد ليونيل ميسي
على ارض الواقع منتخب الكرواتي دفاعه جيد
جدا بوجود ايران وفيتش على الجهه اليمنى
بوجود لوفرين وكبارديول وسوسه او اللاعب
الاخر اللي بيلعب على الجهه اليسرى
بالاضافه الى نص ملعب ممتاز جدا مثل ما
حكينا قبل مباراه البرازيل فيها بروزوفيتش
وفي كوفاسيتش وفي مودريتش هو المسؤول عن
عمليه الخروج بالكره كوفاسيتش والمسؤول عن
عمليه الضغط على المنافس ومودريتش هو
المسؤول عن عمليه نقل الكره من الثلث
الثاني الى الثلث الامامي بالهجوم عنده
بسله وعنده برزنت وعنده همم
اللاعب الاخر اللي بيلعب له هو كمان في
هذا المركز وبالتاكيد خلف كلها هؤلاء عنده
افضل حارس في هذه البطوله حتى
الانوفيتش اللي قدم مستويات كبير امام
المنتخب البرازيلي منتخب كرواتيا ومنتخب
متماسك منتخب صعب الميراث منتخب بيعرف
يقفل المناطق بشكل الصحيح ومن الصعب جدا
على المنتخب الارجنتيني وعلى منتخبات
امريكا اللاتينيه عامه انها تلعب ضد فريق
اوروبي مثل المنتخب الكرواتي لانه
البرازيل حتى البرازيل هي تعتبر افضل كوكب
من اللاعبين امريكا الجنوبيه الموجودين
حاليا لما لعبت مع سويسرا بالدور الاول
سويسرا بتلعب بشكل يعني مقارب لشكل
المنتخب الكرواتي مع شكل دفاعي اكبر
لكرواتيا واجهت صعوبات البرازيل في تلك
المباراه وشفناها امام كرواتيا ايضا
مواجهه صعوبات وخرجت من البطوله وبالتالي
الارجنتين بالنسبه الى القمر راح يكون
بنفس الطريقه وبنفس الاسلوب تركيز المنتخب
الكرواتي كله راح يكون على ايقاف ميسي
ميسي فقط لا غير يعني هو خطوره الارجنتين
الاولى والاخيره وميسي خطورته مش بس هو مع
الكره لا لانه بس خطورته ايضا بانه يفتح
مساحات اللاعبين القادمين من الخلف مثل ما
شفنا بهدف الارجنتين الاول بالمرمى
الهولندي وهو هدف مولينا لما ميسي سحب احد
لاعبي وسط المنتخب الهولندي غالبا كان يوم
وفتح المساحه لمولينا كذلك الحال ممكن
نعمل نفس العمليه مع بروزرتش المباراه ومع
كوفاسيتش ايا كان اللاعب راح يكون موكل
بانه يمسك ميسي اوراق مو خلال هذه
المباراه لذلك مهمه المنتخب الكرواتي
تتلخص بانك تراقب ميسي او انك تحاول تضبط
اداء ميسي في هذه المباراه وتحاولوا
تطلعوا من المباراه اذا بدنا نحكي عن
التوقعات فمنتخب الارجنتين مقارنتا
بالمنتخب الكرواتي عنده الدفاع اضعف عنده
حارس مرمى نسبيا اضعف ولكنه حارس جيد جدا
طبعا هو مليانه ومارتينيز عنده خط هجوم
معقول اقوى من خط هجوم المنتخب الكرواتي
ولكن بكل تاكيد مش هذاك الهجوم المرعب او
اللي قادر يشكل لك 20 او 25 فرصه
بالمباراه الوحده لا هو هجوم متوسط جدا
على قد حاله ولكن عنده قدرات فرديه عن
طريق ديماريه وعن طريق ميسي وغيرهم من
اللاعبين
توقع الشخصي للارجنتين راح تلعب هاي
المباراه بثلاثه خمسه اثنين نفس الطريقه
اللي لعبت فيها امام المنتخب الهولندي
بالمقابل المنتخب الكرواتي راح يلعب بنفس
الطريقه للعب فيها امام المنتخب البرازيلي
وليه طريقه اقرب
الدفاعيه بتصير 4 5 1 وبالتالي
الطريقتين راح يكون متشابهتين جدا برايي
الشخصي انه بهذه المباراه
الارجنتين هي الاقرب للتاهل للدور الثاني
نعم منطقيه من الارجنتين طالما عندها لاعب
بقيمه ليونيل ميسي من اي هفوه من اي غلطه
للدفاع الكرواتي قادر انه يعاقب المنتخب
الكرواتي بالمقابل كرواتي او هجوميا ما
شفناها هذاك المنتخب المرعب اللي كان عام
2018 اللي قادر يشكل خطوره على الارجنتين
ويفوز عليها بثلاث اهداف مقابل لا شيء
شخصيا اتوقع منتخب الارجنتين يعبر الى
نهائي كاس العالم 2022 بالانتقال للموضوع
الاخر اللي الناس او معظم الناس عم تحكي
فيه حاليا وهي الامنيه او الترقب لانه
ميسي يخرج من كاس العالم 2022 هذا الام
بيرجع لنقطه رئيسيه جدا ومهمه جدا بالفتره
الاخيره برايي الشخصي الفتره اللي عايشين
اخر 10 سنين هي من واحده من اسوا فترات
تشجيع بالعالم كره القدم لانه شاهدت حاله
من المناكفات وصلت الى حد الشتائب
والخلافات بسبب ميسي ورونالدو وهذا عزز
طبعا وجود السوشل ميديا اللي خلت ايا كان
يعبر عن رايه ويحكي بالطريقه اللي بتناسبه
ولكن بكل تاكيد الطريقه المسموحه انك تحكي
فيها هي اكيد مش الطريقه اللي بتشتم فيها
ان كان ميسي او رونالدو او بتمنى انه هو
همم يغادر البطوله او انه يطلع بره او انه
ما يحقق اللقب لانه بالنهايه ميسي او
رونالدو الاثنين من افضل لاعبين العالم من
افضل من مره على كره القدم العالميه هنا
اثنين رسخوا تاريخ جديد بالعالم كره القدم
كسروا كل الارقام الممكنه وبالتالي يجب
انك تستمتع فيهم الاثنين يجب انك تتمنى
انه يحققوا الالقاب ويجيبوا البطولات لحتى
يكونوا دائما بالقمه وتح انه كره القدم
كافاتهم على ما فعلوها على مدار سنوات
الماضيه مش بانك تتمنى انه يطلعوا بره او
انه يصير مشهد مثل شفناه مع كرستيانو
رونالدو يطلع بيبكي من الملعب بس لمجرد
ماك حابب تشمت بصديقك او بصديقتك او باي
كان الشخص الاخر وتنزل بوست على السوشيال
ميديا تحفل فيه على ميسي وتحفل فيه على
رونالدو هاي مش طريقه تشجيع هاي مش كره
قدم بكل امانه مين محقق لقب كاس العالم
الف مبروك ولكن لا احد يحب كره القدم لا
يتمنى انه ميسي او رونالدو يجيبه كاس
العالم 2022 في قطر لحتى تكافئهم مثل ما
حكينا كره القدم على كل السنوات اللي
قدموها للكره هذه رساله بحب اوجهها لكل
الجماهير بتمنى انه الناس فعلا تستغل كل
لحظه تستغل كل ثانيه موجود فيها ميسي
ورونالدو داخل ارضيه الملعب وبنستمتع فيهن
حتى الرمق الاخير
واعتزالهم كره القدم بشكل نهائي
[موسيقى]